tja im Osten nichts Neues Professor
Andreas heinemann-grüder ich grüße Sie
ganz herzlich
die werden jetzt noch gesagt hätte die
Erde ist eine Scheibe hätten hätten es
wahrscheinlich auch alle glauben müssen
glaubt Herr Putin also er hat den
gleichen Kram erzählt wie von Anfang an
Nazis und Genozid und so weiter oder
also er will dem Normalität
demonstrieren er will demonstrieren
trotz der Sanktionen sind wir mit
unserem Weltraumprogramm weiter vorne
wir sind eine technologienationen und
wird werden durch die Sanktionen wie
schon zu sowjetszeiten auch nicht
eingeschränkt in unseren Möglichkeiten
man stimmt sich auch mit Weißrussland so
ein bisschen beim Propagandakrieg ab
sozusagen wie man dann auch das Publikum
zu Hause wechselt seit ich bedient
interessant ist dass ich das narrativ
leicht geändert hat und zwar in der
Vergangenheit war immer nur von Don
Basti rede jetzt wird plötzlich von
einem Präventivkrieg quasi gesprochen
gegenüber borussland sich quasi
gegenüber einem Angriff der entweder vom
Westen insgesamt oder von den Nazis in
der Ukraine
gestartet worden wäre gegen den hätte
man sich gewehrt also es ist nicht nur
die Entnazifizierung sondern letztlich
ein Präventivkrieg den man unmittelbar
abgewendet hat
das ist ein neuer Zungenschlag das heißt
jetzt hier diese Truppenbewegung wir
schauen mal ein bisschen noch auf die
auf die Strategie Putins in Richtung
Osten also Donbass Lugansk und Don jetzt
und dann vielleicht noch mariopol und
den ganzen so ein landrüssel an den an
den Meeren entlang ist nicht sein Ziel
allein nur oder was glauben Sie ich
glaube dass er sich im Moment auf eine
Entscheidungsschlacht im Osten der
Ukraine konzentriert weil die Truppen
sehr im Norden im Osten und auch im
Süden also schwarzmeerregionen
auseinandergezogen waren gleichzeitig
dann auch noch die Belagerung von Kiew
stattfand und man jetzt eine
Entscheidungsschlacht letztlich in
don-bass sucht wenn man die gewinnt hat
man vielleicht auch die ukrainische
Streitkräfte so geschwächt dass man dann
auf weitere Ziele
hinausgehen kann also insbesondere auch
Schwarzmeerregion insofern würde ich
jetzt nicht vom Strategiewechsel
sprechen sondern von der Konzentration
auf eine Entscheidungsschlacht mit der
man die Ukraine
und Schwächen und auch demoralisieren
kann das heißt
da hat sich etwas verändert an sich aber
die hat die gesamte Ukraine immer noch
im Blick sagen sie ja meines Erachtens
hatte sie immer noch im Blick wir wissen
nicht genau was er mit der
endmalletarisierung und Enden
hatifizierung der gesamten Ukraine meint
das Ziel wird nach wie vor hoch gehalten
gestern hat zum Beispiel der russische
Außenminister lavrov gesagt ein
Kriegsziel wäre auch die Dominanz der
USA in den internationalen Beziehungen
zu überwinden also ein extrem exzessives
neues Kriegsziel das da in der Ukraine
verfolgt wird präzise ist das nicht
insofern würde ich aber warnen davor das
Putin sich jetzt eigentlich nur auf den
Don Bass konzentriert sondern das Ziel
ist nach wie vor eigentlich eine
Vernichtung der Ukraine als unabhängiger
souveräner Staat hat sich ja mit
lukaschen dass sie beide dann
Sicherheitsgarantien abgeben sollen
russische Truppen
welche Rolle spielt Belarus überhaupt
luca schenko ist bisher Aufmarschgebiet
gewesen er hat sich aber selber als
garantiemacht für einen Friedensschluss
dann angeboten also im Sinne von
weißrussische Truppen dann auch auf
ukrainischem Territorium die dann quasi
die endmilitarisierung zusammen mit
Russland garantieren sollen das zweite
sie stimmen sich in Bezug auf den
gastransit natürlich ab also wann wird
auch möglicherweise der gastransit der
ja nach wie vor durch Weißrussland auch
nach Polen und nach Deutschland
stattfindet als Waffe eingesetzt also
darüber findet eine Abstimmung statt und
dann natürlich auch die militärische
Unterstützung für die russischen
Operationen diese Rolle spielt er und
gleichzeitig ist Lukaschenko auch einer
der über seine Medien quasi so eine
Rückendeckung für die Propaganda
Schlacht putinschaft also heißt also in
Russland wird sozusagen wenn die
Erkenntnisse aus Weißrussland zitiert
wir müssen wir noch ganz kurz über etwas
reden es gibt viele Besucher derzeit die
nach wir Freisen die in die Ukraine
reisen drei Abgeordnete vom Bundestag
allein schon und jetzt gibt es eine
Nachricht das Frank-Walter Steinmeier
der jetzt gerade nach Polen auch gereist
ist in der Ukraine in Kiew derzeit nicht
willkommen sei
was heißt das
ich glaube der Steinmeier immer noch
auch in der Ukraine als ein
putinversteher oder Vertreter sozusagen
der alten sozialdemokratischen Politik
oder der großen Koalition angesehen wird
die lange Zeit der Ansicht waren die
Ukraine dürfe keine Waffen bekommen also
weder Defensive noch Offensive Waffen
Steinmeier steht letztlich für die
Modernisierungspartnerschaft für die
dialogpolitik mit Putin und da das bis
zum 24 Februar der Fall war bis zum
Kriegsbeginn ist er quasi
moralisch diskreditiert und man will ihn
nicht sozusagen jetzt die Möglichkeit
geben sich in Kiew durch einen Besuch
selber von seiner Vergangenheit weiß zu
waschen und es wird ja auch noch der
Druck erhöht auf den Kanzler sich dort
zu überblicken zu lassen da hört man
noch nichts Neues Professor Heinemann
grünreich ich danke Ihnen ganz herzlich
dass sie im Studio waren